the Food and Drug Administration has
announced that they'll be cracking down
on vaping they're cracking down on
vaping sorry dude it's the guy in the
douchey hat anyway they're gonna be
cracking down on vaping companies who
purposely designed their product to
appeal to young children check this out
apparently the company's already this is
true selves aping items that look like
juice boxes and different types of candy
that's real and it's become a major
problem so I was curious to learn how
the general public feels about this so I
sent our camera crew into the
neighborhood just a couple hours ago and
here's what they said yeah I definitely
think it's right that the FDA is
stepping in you don't want young kids
thinking it's cool to babe you know I
say yes absolutely regulate them we
cannot have these vape companies
targeting our children I'll be honest
with you I think they're overreacting
it's not like young children even know
what they think they do they can't just
walk into a baby
[Music]
you